bonjour bienvenue sur ce premier
tutoriel qui vous apprendre à comprendre
dynamique et des structures des villages
européens en donnant des airs
la source utilisée le manuel que vous
connaissez désormais géo 3,6 des
éditions de bouc
p1 les territoires européens nous semble
parfois difficiles à analyser est
difficile parfois de dégager des traits
communs tous ces territoires ruraux des
régions tempérées ce qu'on va faire ici
c'est vraiment analyser et ça vous
permettra de comprendre qu'on regarde un
paysage tous les éléments qui peuvent
s'y retrouver
alors de manière générale le site
apparaît comme un élément important pour
comprendre l'organisation du territoire
le relief l'hydrographie sont souvent
des éléments déterminants dans le choix
d'un lieu par une communauté pour
s'installer
il regarde évidemment la pente du
terrain une exposition favorable du
terrain par rapport aux vents dominants
au soleil ou plutôt ex président une
exposition au sud qu'au nord le
proximité d'une source d'eau parce que
l'eau c'est à la fois utile pour la vie
de tous les jours mais aussi la lot
c'est une source d'énergie
on va d'abord s'installer là parce que
c'est facile d'installer un moulin à eau
qui va permettre d'avoir un point pour
moudre le grain aussi des zones
inondables vont être évités donc chaque
fois il ya un rapport par rapport à
l'igs l'hydrographie qu'on va rechercher
ou éviter mais a néanmoins on va pas d'y
faire sa diversité des lieux occupés par
les centres villageois montre que
d'autres éléments naturels comme le sol
la qualité du sol ou d'autres facteurs
comme les axes de communication ont
parfois influencé cette installation la
structure commune des différents
villages européen c'est l'aurait hall
villageoise autour de l'église et de la
place du village l'habitat et groupée et
est associée à des jardins des vergers
des petite prairie
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'oréal
villageoise autour de celle ci ait eu
des défrichements on a coupé les bois
qui se trouvait là le forez qui s'y
trouvaient des défrichements successifs
qui ont permis aux villageois qu'ils
étaient en majorité des agriculteurs au
moyen-age de mettre les parcelles en
culture c'est ce qu'on appelle les
labours ou de lait destinées à l'élevage
du bétail
ce sont des prairies autrement dit des
pâtures aussi pour la pâture des animaux
la répartition des labourés des pâtures
et souvent
influencé par l'humidité du sol les
labours réclament des terres plus sèche
tandis que les seconds s'accommode de
terre plus humide
on va donc les retrouver plus tôt dans
les fonds des vallées ou par la
proximité des fermes le bétail réclament
de nombreux soins et donc on va mettre
les prairies plus proche des habitations
que les champs qui n'ont pas besoin de
l'assistance de l'homme plus loin
subsistent les vestiges de la forêt qui
recouvre celle qui recouvrait ses
régions tempérées
cette forêt a parfois totalement disparu
dans les régions les plus densément
peuplées ou des friches pour avoir de la
place pour habiter et pour élever et
cultiver l'ensemble des terres
exploitées traditionnellement par la
communauté villageoise porte le nom de
finale cette organisation de l'espace
constitue donc un exemple d'un modèle
d'un centre autour duquel s'organise une
paire y faire les changements que
connaît l'agriculture au jour
d'aujourd'hui ont des conséquences
importantes dans les campagnes
l'agrandissement des exploitations la
réduction de leur nombre et leur
spécialisation transforme les paysages
ruraux exemple on va voir la
construction de nouveaux bâtiments à
l'école mais aussi la suppression des
haies entre les différents terrains et
ce qu'on appelle le remembrement
agricole et donc sa conduite où ça a
modifié le paysage et à l'uniformiser le
remembrement de quoi s'agit-il
vous voyez ici suivre les deux photos
qui vous sont proposés à gauche vous
avez une société d'une situation avant
le remembrement et à droite une
situation après le remembrement le
remembrement
c'est juste le fait que des agriculteurs
vont regrouper les terrains agricoles
qui avant à partenaires des agriculteurs
différents donc je vais le même parcelle
on va maintenant cultiver une
monoculture alors qu'avant il s'agissait
de plusieurs parcelles
l'organisation du territoire qui vient
d'être décrite est assez générale
jusqu'au 19ème siècle pour des raisons
souvent socio-économique augmentation la
population proximité d'une ville
importante
certaines régions se sont spécialisés
dans les cultures et d'autres dans
l'élevage
cette spécialisation abouti à deux types
de paysages différents
l'opl field à droite où le beau gage sur
l'image de gauche vouloir rattacher
chaque région à l'un de ces deux modèles
serait une erreur car la plupart des cas
les fermes ont continué à produire des
denrées issues de la 2d culture du blé
maïs betterave la pomme de terre et de
l'élevage l'élu beurre de la viande
néanmoins connaître les caractéristiques
de ces deux types de paysages permet de
mieux comprendre la dynamique des
territoires ruraux d'aujourd'hui dans
les régions d'open field à droite sur
l'écran
l'habitat est très groupée l'oréal
villageoise est encore bien marquer et
dans le finage les parcelles cultivées
domine largement le réseau routier est
peu dense et forme une étoile à partir
du centre du village
les parcelles cultivées ne sont pas
entouré de clôtures
elles sont nombreuses et quelques
bosquets sont disséminés dans le final
la vue porte très loin on parle alors de
paysages ouverts dans les régions
bocagères comme à droite le centre du
village reste identifiable mais
l'habitat est dispersé
l'activité dominante et l'élevage ce qui
nécessite pour l'agriculteur d'être à
proximité de son cheptel nécessitant des
soins quotidiens
cette dispersion a entraîné un réseau
très dense de routes de chemins mais
aussi des petits sentiers les prairies
domine largement et sont entourés de
clôture naturelle des haies ou
artificielle avec des fils barbelés ou
électriques les et les rangées d'arbres
les bosquets plus nombreux et l'habitat
dispersé ne permettent pas de voir très
loin
on parle de paysages fermé évidemment
pour un observateur qui est au sol à
droite on aura une vue à perdre de vue
justement
dans les cas gauche on aura la vision
qui est vite coupé par une rangée
d'arbres ou une habitation
donc évidemment si vous voulez faire une
photographie en région bocagères il vaut
mieux alors à ce moment-là privilégier
une vue aérienne oblique tandis que dans
la région d'open field on peut se
contenter d'une prise de vue au sol
enfin sur l'image que vous avez à
l'écran vous voyez en bas à gauche et à
droite des plans de ces deux régions
alors on va en voir un plan beaucoup
plus complexe évidemment dans les
régions bocagères tandis que dans les
régions d'open filt on va voir
directement visuellement sur la carte de
grandes étendues qui vont apparaître
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a appris
des choses
j'espère aussi que vous avez pris les
notes utile parce que vous devez
considérer tout ce qui a été présenté
ici comme de la matière d'examen sur
laquelle vous serez bien sûr évalué à
certains moments n'oubliez pas aussi
votre lexique beaucoup de mof faisant
partie du lexique ont été évoqués ici et
si vous avez des questions je serai à
votre disposition pour répondre en
classe je vous demande aussi maintenant
de cliquer sur le lien que vous pouvez
en dessous de la vidéo et qui va vous
conduire un petit questionnaire de cinq
questions qui vous permettront de gagner
bien sûr si vous avez été attentifs les
questions sont très faciles voilà je
vous souhaite une bonne fin de journée
et je vous souhaite à bien nous dit à
bientôt et je vous donne rendez bordel
pourquoi